devant le commissariat un policier vient
d'être blessé
les forces de l'ordre répliquent tirs de
grenades lacrymogènes panique dans les
rangs des lycéens qui rebroussent chemin
les 23 qu'on lançait d'été ou qu'ils ont
gazés tout le monde quoi
on n'a plus rien puis après nous avons
du coup on est complètement dans le
fumier on peut plus respirer enfin merde
on m'a dit c'est tout quoi faut se
calmer appelés à bloquer leurs lycées
dès ce matin ils sont plus d'un millier
à se regrouper pour une longue marche
d'établissement en établissement
sur manifester parce qu arrive à un
moment
on dirait on dit rien mais être pris
pour des abrutis ça commence à aller un
peu trop loin c'est à dire avec toutes
les nouvelles réformes tout ce qui se
passe je fais que les classes ne soient
plus des doubles et que l'on va être
beaucoup et d'élèves dans une classe et
le fait que les professeurs ne puisse
plus être autant à notre écoute et
autant à nous accompagner dans nos
exercices quand on n'y arrive pas tout
ça c'est pour par rapport à la réforme
avec les professeurs mais les gens ils
viennent comme ça je pense un périple
débuté dans le calme émaillées
d'incidents et de heurts avec les forces
de l'ordre
jusqu'en milieu d'après midi entre temps
les lycéens recevait le soutien d'un
premier syndicat enseignant la réforme
du lycée
la réforme de la voix propose une
épuisette augmentation annoncée des
frais d'université nous sommes nous
partageons si ce sont bien celles des
lycéens avec qui nous n'avons pas de
contacts directs en ce moment si ce sont
bien celles des lycéens ce sont des
revendications que nous soutenons
effectivement pour nous c'est des
réformes qui vont appauvrir le degré
d'instruction enfin surtout en tout cas
appauvrir la valeur du diplôme
les personnels d'éducation du lycée le
castel solidaires de leurs élèves se
réuniront demain matin pour décider de
la suite à donner à ce mouvement de
protestation